thank you all for coming
this event sponsored by the
which for 35 years has brought
distinguished journalists to campus and
has given Yale students a unique
opportunity to learn more about the
world of journalism and its role in
society this lecture is being recorded
so please turn off your mobile devices
if you have a question for mr. Woodward
there are ushered on this side on with
note cards and pens and they can give
you a note card and take your question
as well once it's written I'm Paul
Needham I'm a senior in Yale College on
studying journalism if this were the s80
and the question were who on stage does
not belong here the answer would be me
uh-huh but I was the editor of the Yale
Daily News until October and I'm very
happy to be here and to introduce Steve
Brill who is the co-founder of press +
and e-commerce platform that allows
publishers to collect revenue from their
online readers Brill teachers a
journalism seminar at Yale where he
established the Yale journalism
initiative aimed at channeling students
into the profession after working his
way through Yale Law School by writing
magazine articles from New York and
Harper's magazines Brill became a legal
columnist for Esquire is the founder of
the American Lawyer magazine and Court
TV and is the author of the Teamsters
and after how America confronted the
September 12 era over the last year
Burrell has written the rubber room for
The New Yorker and the teachers unions
last stand for the New York Times
Magazine he is now working on a book
about the Battle of our American public
education Bob Woodward has written 16
non-fiction books in the last 36 years
all 16 of them have been national
bestsellers and 12 have been number one
national best sellers for his latest
book obama's wars he interviewed many
more documents in order to chronicle the
evolution of President Obama's
Afghanistan policy is worked for The
Washington Post since 1971 as a reporter
and is currently an associate editor at
the paper while young reporter at the
post in 1972 Woodward was teamed up with
Carl Bernstein
the two did much of the original news
reporting on the Watergate scandal that
led to numerous government
investigations and the eventual
resignation of President Richard Nixon
jean-robert's the former managing editor
of the New York Times has called the
work of Woodward and Bernstein may be
the single greatest reporting effort of
all time Bob Woodward has shared in
winning two Pulitzer Prizes and is on
campus today to receive the walter
cronkite award this evening from the
Connecticut Freedom of Information
Society welcome so my job is to put some
questions to Bob which Paul will also do
that I'll just begin with the
observation and I was really loving the
description of my resume until you shift
it over to Bob I just feel like nothing
here but I'll try I guess I want to
start Bob with a basic bedrock question
you have sitting there on that table
what I consider to be a really important
book and it's a terrific read but what
gets you up in the morning at your age
you're the only one in this room I think
solder than I am because I have to go to
the bathroom that's it that's only the
first four times you get up in yeah
let's do the fifth time I'm what makes
you still believe that books like this
which was you know the inner workings of
the White House who's writing a memo to
whom and why they're doing this and why
is this stuff so important first because
government particularly the presidency
it's such a concentration of power these
days it's astonishing what the president
can do I was talking to the daily news
editors and reporters before lunch and
telling how a couple of years ago I was
talking to some academics who were
saying well Congress
declares war and I said no but the
president has the power of the president
is the commander-in-chief and he can
employ the force as he sees fit and they
just would you know the Constitution
rules that's what happens i said in
practice it's very different and made
the point that president bush could
invade mexico tomorrow and somebody
stood up in the back in agony and said
don't give him any ideas and i'm not
trying to give anyone any ideas but
there is that power they can do the
things that week it's obvious in a way
the bully pulpit the managed message
each day the wars the sense now of obama
being in a decline or trough in part
because he hasn't fixed the economy well
as we know presidents don't fix the
economy so there is that concentration
of power and but I think the more direct
answer to your question is there are
always hiding things the picture in the
daily weekly media is always incomplete
you compare with what we knew about
Obama before this book and after this
book and somebody who works in the White
House said it quadruples our knowledge
of exactly what he says what his values
are when he gets frustrated and so forth
so there's the opportunity to do that
and then I think there is the factor
which you and I've talked about over the
years that going back to Watergate a
process has evolved to interview people
go back again and again look for
contemporaneous notes and documents and
then go back again do drafts try to fill
out the story get the complete picture
and to see over many decades that
process work it takes a lot of time it
can involve a lot of hard work but in
sense the process of is never fail you
you do a lot of this and you do it
really masterfully here by going and
doing just that talking to all the
people who were sitting in the room and
asking them what happened if they kept
notes of what was going on you try to
get their notes and that's important
because the work that's going on is
important so suppose you had a research
assistant on the Brethren All the
President's Men or all right hey so so
cause pause Impala job yeah because you
you do always you know you're always I'm
acknowledging you know one or more
research assistants in these books um
suppose one of those research assistants
kept avid notes of what you were doing
and how you were doing it and how you
were making decisions and who you were
talking to and decided to write a little
memoir about it what would you think of
it gee I'd really be unhappy and what I
do i interviewed the people i hire
extensively i say that this process is
going to be open to you you're going to
know who the sources are we have a
sacred obligation to keep those sources
secret and we sign a contract that
specifies this very in its Nora detailed
Turner shirt right here the people the
president hires if they haven't signed
that I think they handwriting they
certainly orally heaven they probably
have in fact they probably would run
against various statutes if the
information they're giving you as they
often do is classified so tell me why
it's okay for them to do that and not
for Paul to do that to you okay first
the again it goes back to the presidency
is important i'm on the outside i'm an
outlier here and you've only over thrown
one president that's the other day oh
yeah well but it and what you find is
all the cooperation of the people is
voluntary I'm not coercing anyone and I
was telling this story beginning of the
work on this I went to the White House
and talk to one of Obama's aides who
said I said I'm doing the book and it's
going to be on national security and he
said you know good luck kid you won't
find many [ __ ] here by the end of
the process this person was getting out
his top secret notes from his safe and
reading them to me for the purpose of
clarifying filling it in that the
story's already going to be told so it's
an incremental process with lots of
people to a certain extent sanctioned by
the president but not to this extent his
you know he's they're shocked that
there's so much detail we can do it
because they know you're going to do the
work anyway yes and I hope they think
that it's neutral inquiry that it's not
with any political perspective either
partisan or for Obama or against Obama
and you're not for the students of mine
and other students in here you're not
doing it by sending out email inquiries
to them you're not hoping they call you
you're knocking on doors and going if
you in fig tell everybody the story you
told my class hope I've got it for the
last Bush book yeah there was a general
who just wouldn't talk wouldn't respond
to emails wouldn't respond to phone
calls so I found out not hard where he
lived and showed up at eight-fifteen
actually 817 is the perfect time for a
drop in unannounced unscheduled
interview because at 8 17 8 15 people
have already eaten they haven't gotten
to bed unless they're george bush and
they're the evening has got kind of an
undirected quality so I knocked on the
door at 8 15 8 17 and the general came
to the door and looked at me and just
kind of wagged his head a little bit and
said are you still doing this [ __ ]
and answers you got to do this [ __ ] yeah
exactly and so he you know there was a
moment there where he was going to say
I'm sorry don't you haven't you don't
you know what no means I haven't
answered your inquiries and he finally
did you know come on in and he answered
questions and helped in a incredibly
significant way now I'm sure you
encounter all this and at the Daily News
you encountered a reporter says oh I you
know so-and-so won't talk I don't have
so and so's phone number I can't and you
know that the answer to that is it's
easy to get phone numbers and after
somebody says no 12 times maybe you can
accept it but not up to that point and
if they're vital to the story go visit
him has each administration been more or
less the same in terms of the number of
people saying no or were different
administration's tougher to cart that's
a good question I've it you can always
find a core group of people who will
respond and so I think I think they're
all hard I think Bush and Obama
particularly hard because they have well
crafted well in place apparatus embedded
in the White House to manage the message
as they wanted managed and so that you
come along and say well I'm going to
tell the story not you and you get
varying levels of cooperation convince
them it's a neutral inquiry and we've
talked about this before you convince
people you're taking them as seriously
as they take themselves which is that
people take themselves seriously
particularly in Washington it low level
mid-level high-level posts and if you
show a real interest in a persistence
that there is a bit of the secret sharer
and everyone who wants to tell what's
the difference between navigating that
challenge
with the white house versus the book you
did about the Supreme Court that's it's
oddly enough very much the same and it's
process in the Supreme Court book the
Brethren which came out my god 31 years
ago is it could it possibly be that long
about the Warren Berger court five of
the sitting Justice has helped us maybe
a hundred and sixty clerks friends and
other people and again it was going
every clerk in the Supreme Court they
all denied that they ever kept any notes
or documents but they all have notes and
documents in their attic or their
basement and you have to get enough of
them and so we had extensive
documentation about what we wrote about
the United saying why did the clerk's
ultimately talk in some cases I you know
what was nice I never went to law school
and I got an education and
constitutional law from the law clerks
and the justices and they were so part
of it was educating me and part of it
was telling the story and if we did a
matrix and this is a little boring about
method and we covered seven Supreme
Court terms and so you do each term 69
70 70 71 up to 75 76 and then you do
nine chambers actually 10 because
Douglas was replaced by stevens and then
you say do we have a source that year in
this chambers and it turned out that
with five justices helping answering
basic questions you cover almost
everything they talk about other
justices we get memos and it got to the
point where sometimes we had 16 sources
in one chambers for one Supreme Court
term so it was
covered very extensively and though you
may recall when that book came out it
was people were enraged lawyers
particularly half the lawyers said we
don't dare know this we shouldn't really
look at it and the other half of the
lawyers saying we already knew it and it
now even Linda greenhouse who didn't
like the book wrote in one of her books
that the Brethren is accurate according
to the Justice Blackmun's papers the
other thing he suffered from with that
was the people reviewing the book we're
typically reporters who covered the
supreme court so they were basically
writing their editors a memo about why
you didn't cover the court any better
than they did that's a little harsh but
you specialize in debunking of one want
to take that let me ask you something
when you do these books they're all
narratives and they're all fly on the
wall narratives and they're not sourced
although they there's some notes and but
your your basic lots of documents lots
of documents in fact this book in
particular people over documents
important but you're basically telling
the reader I really did talk to these
people and this is what they really say
happened but I'm really not offering the
person who might be the target of what
these people are saying happen I'm not
offering them and on the record
opportunity in the book to respond and
say no this didn't happen or it didn't
happen that way you listen to all the
people and then you make your judgment
and you write the narrative the winds
you think it happened now I don't know
that's not a terrible problem it's the
book you're reading is Bob Woodward but
don't you think it's fair to say that
that launched a thousand other reporters
on that style of unsourced journalism I
don't think of a thousand and the you
know that when you're dealing with
classified information or sensitive
meetings or negotiations no way am I is
somebody going to tell me on the record
that Afghan President Karzai is at
diagnosed manic-depressive which is in
the book are that the Ambassador comes
back to Washington says well Karzai's on
his meds off his meds and when that came
out in the book karzai's spokesman came
out and said we want you to know the
president is on no medication and
everyone went oh my god that's the
problem we want him on his medication so
it you can verify it the this book i
think for strategic reasons the White
House is embraced and not argued with
anything it is one of those things where
you triangulate and you get it so it's
an accurate narrative is one of the
critics of one of my books pointed out
it is not an engineer's drawing of what
happened it is not a tape-recorded and
if we had taped recordings of everything
I report I think the it would show that
it's basically right I think there are
things that are missed things that you
know are not exactly an engineer's
drawing but to do that I would say is
impossible and would mean a four-volume
book let's talk a bit about Afghanistan
which what the book is about what is
victory in Afghanistan for President
Obama yeah that's a great question Paul
and Obama poses it in the secret
strategy sessions that they have but it
never really gets answered and as you
may have noticed since those the
strategy review last fall where he
decided to send 30,000 troops he does
not use the word victory or winning I
thought of calling the book the divided
man that he knows he has to lead he's
commander-in-chief he inherited this war
it's America's war
he promised during the campaign he was
going to add more resources but the
other side of him of this divide is he's
very cerebral he's a law professor and
identifies all of the issues that make
winning or victory or some sort of
stability unlikely if not improbable and
so he sees the dreary side he realizes
he has to lead and I think he
communicates that I think in a sense
it's his persona not just on these
national security issues I think it's
his persona on lots of things take
health care which he drove home but he
was for the public option no he was
against the public option there's a lot
of I would argue that this is the first
time you see him as he really is and you
know some people want editor it Simon &
Schuster the publisher read and said it
shows him totally indecisive it's a
catastrophe and other editor said it
shows a very forceful determined leader
so you can read into it many things the
great scene in the book is the time i
think is where he actually writes the
five page in a single space decision
memo okay here's what we're doing but
secret orders yeah it's classified
secret and he you see him frustrated
with the military in the Pentagon and
those secret orders which are published
in the back of the book really tell you
what his intent is which is to get out
of Afghanistan he tells the military
more what they can't do rather than what
they can 10 or 20 years now it's called
20 years from now or we forget you and
me actually we but is someone going to
be able to sit here and have a
conversation with a reporter who is able
to make a successful career out of doing
the kind of journalism you do that's
good question i think so Paul and I
talked about this at lunch tell them
what you project 50 years
from now he's gonna laugh at me but okay
I said I mean I think journalism is
going to be profitable and I think
journalists will be highly paid and by
the end of my career I mean people are
reading more than ever before um we were
talking about all the different papers
we read on a daily basis and the Denver
Post kids on campus reading The Denver
Post because it's all available so you
have more people reading than ever
before news matters as much as ever
before oh we just need to start paying
for it yeah it's finding the business
model but this I'm going to run around
the country from now on and say there's
this guy at Yale who was editor the
Daily News who's optimist is out of his
life now he says in in 50 years the
course I didn't a doctrine what's going
to happen in the intervening time
between now I'll tell you one one thing
actually pretty easy to predict if you
have a brand like Bob Woodward he is you
know our our friend Alice me who your
editor you like this but if you have a
brand like Bob or would you have no need
for Simon & Schuster the publisher yeah
because you can sell they don't tell me
that like for some reason yeah i know
but that's there's added value and there
our relationship I mean I've let me as
we're going through this i want to tell
you something it's me what's that your
ulcer ok that's ok now it's really all
in painting my Bob when I was an
undergraduate here in the early 60s and
I always found myself somewhat at war
with the way people were taught and that
there was too much finding out what you
read and regurgitating it and what the
professor's said and not enough real
kind of critical thinking and I worry on
something like this I worry about
the government knowing its capacity to
conceal and hide whether we've got
enough people working on this whether
there's an apparatus in place to really
penetrate what's occurring and I get
waves of confidence and waves of lack of
confidence about that and the ultimately
I mean I I share your optimism it will
it's like automobiles it's like shoes
it's like blackberries it's the quality
of the product if we enhance the quality
of the journalistic product people are
going to say ah you know we used to joke
at the post what was called a story that
was I called him a holy [ __ ] story
better term is a bacon cooler that
you're reading the morning paper and you
have bacon on the fork and it the story
so good the bacon gets cold on the fork
because you have to read the story
because it's so compelling so relevant
to your life and yet even leaving
Washington is that if you look at the
coverage of state capitals for example
it's it where you know they prize
secrecy even more than in Washington
it's hard to argue that you have
anything approaching that kind of
coverage anymore in most places yes
that's right and I would predict that
there's going to be something we're
going to miss that's really an important
story and it's there's going to be such
a collective getting into the hair shirt
about it on the part of the media and
the owners and the country that people
are going to say we got to fix it and I
agree your solution is they have to pay
for the news this idea of the news and
what you read being free is something
that you know I'd like to know who got
the idea first and make sure that person
gets jailed because it should it never
should have happened well when you get
back to the post you can you can call
the police or a lot
people to put in jail there yeah yeah
that's right they piled on but I don't
think they were first thought they were
first it was first probably did it might
have been the times of the major New
York I don't know but they all sort of
everybody did it once because it was the
cool thing to do yours well it wasn't
that it was cool it was going to we're
going to get five times the readership
so we get five times the ad revenue and
there was an equivalency that took place
that was mindless let me come back to to
your craft for a minute what is it other
than showing up 10 or 12 times if you
were advising any of the people here who
want to be journalists what's the best
way to get people to want to share
information with you even secrets with
you that could get them in a lot of
trouble you know is it like the movie
where you're the nice guy and dumb in
Carl's the you know you know the tough
guy it's as ever saying you know you you
show that you're as interested in them
as they are in themselves and you show
you've done your homework everything in
the media is driven by impatience in
speed now I'm the opposite I'm patient
and slow real slow and you show that
they're reporters at the post I've
worked with who will go schedule
interviews with major figures for an
hour and there was actually a transcript
of one of them interviewing the key
person in government saying oh I've got
to go now because I have an interview it
two o'clock with somebody else well
that's you know I'm I don't leave
anything when I went to see the general
when I go to the White House when I go
wherever or have somebody over to my
house there's nothing at the back end
not zero at the back end and if the
interview goes for four hours it's
really good if it goes for more than
four hours it's exceptional used to when
we're working on Watergate had reporters
notebook the rule was if you fill one
side of the paper and you have to turn
it over you real you're really into a
good interview because it's long long
interviews matter how much do you hold
back because you get all these facts and
all these secrets in the process of
reporting your books what do you hold
back how do you choose what to hold back
you ask people what's there has to be a
reason to hold it back and it's going to
kill people get people killed or
interrupt operations military or
intelligence operations you listen to
the argument and I try not to give so
much detail or there's one thing in this
book where somebody in the Intel world
told I said went through a whole list of
things and said how about out of the
Richter scale 0 to 10 what is this and
he said a 9 and made an argument for why
it shouldn't be in the book and it's not
in the book because it would get people
killed and caused the disruption on a
incredible scale that it's a good story
I'm saving it for my memoirs why don't
you just tell us a little bit how about
what just you know what's the subject
yeah yeah let's see this is the problem
we've got all these recording devices
going and we're not sitting in my hair
it's not like we can just trust everyone
yeah we could play it off the record
yeah exactly I tell the story about
Katharine Graham he had this she always
had dinners and lunches and receptions
at her house and if he went as a
reporter absolutely off the record
totally off the record nothing can be
used and then a year or two after I was
at the post she called me one morning
she said the secretary of defense was
here for dinner and he had the greatest
most interesting stories up wait a
minute while I go get my notes that I
wrote out before
I went to bed this is the kind of
publisher you love and then she told us
that said what it was we checked it out
when something's off the record you
can't seal it away and got two or three
good stories and she always was kind of
oh the social events are sacrosanct and
you know we're not using them for
business horse manure and I would always
say to her we have alway is that under
the Graham modification of off the
record which is it will not absolutely
and totally can't be used unless it's
really good what um you told me ask you
this I'm curious what the answer is what
was the most painful lesson you learned
at Yale you actually just asked a
question that he told you to ask yeah
yeah because it's red this is painful
this is painful and it's a loaded two in
All the President's Men whatwhat have in
freshman history the professor we had
these documents that we were supposed to
read and it was about canosa which is a
incident in the 11th century where the
French King I think went to give penance
to the Pope yeah that's absolutely right
any-any stood you know that you know
your 17th century history and he stood
in the snow for three days in his bare
feet and all the documents were
witnesses saying no it was there two and
a half days no he was there one point
three days so I read these documents and
I wrote calculated that the King had
stood in the snow and his bare feet 42.7
out days and we all got the paper back
and I got an F F and that hurt while
said that hurts what it's a b-plus that
I ok
or nay minus right Brill only gives it
yeah is that right and so f my god zero
I think we run yet we was zero and
everyone in the class or yeah I think
everyone in the class got 20 and he said
now you have all these documents and all
this testimony and the thing you have
failed to bring to your study of these
documents in this problem I've given you
is the most important thing you have
which is common sense common sense tells
you and it's in the documents that the
this could not have happened because the
king then put his shoes back on and went
walking away and you know if you stand
in the snow and your bare feet for a
couple of hours you probably get for us
by three days didn't happen common sense
tells you that now so in the Watergate
case the prosecutors who are
investigating Watergate said we've got
all this testimony from these people
John Mitchell Lewis the former attorney
general Nixon's campaign manager we had
nothing to do with Watergate and they
indicted the five burglars and gordon
Liddy in howard hunt who were kind of
the operational managers of this and
they tried them and the prosecutor went
into court and said gordon Liddy was the
mastermind and it goes no higher no
higher ups who were involved fine you
know convict them and let's move on we
were writing stories they know all the
higher-ups finance this they were
involved they were aware of it and
remember talking to the prosecutor about
it and I said you know you've got he
said we've got all this evidence and I
said did you ever study canosa where's
your common sense and he would say well
but you know the grand Mitchell denied
this and the grand jury and there's all
of this and you looked at his case and
they gave out 190,000 dollars in cash
the gordon Liddy from the Nixon campaign
for this operation and if you study you
see that John Mitchell was approving how
much they spent on pencils there is no
way he didn't know what this was for and
the common sense element is you know
something that's not in the documents or
the interviews and I tell you I'll never
forget it do you what's an example you
know today where you pick up where
you're seeing a story today he said that
just defies common sense there has to be
more to that story than that wow I was I
read the news this morning they say that
the the anti cigarette people were
giving out slices of pizza to the people
who turned in their cigarettes and if
you turned in a whole pack you've got a
whole pizza in 40 years they're going to
be doing the story about if you give
celery sticks they're going to give the
pizzas bad because it beats us or as
dangerous as the cigarettes but we have
that hasn't quite caught up yet and as I
was walking around the old campus today
outside there was a group of six people
who are were giving out cigarettes and
cigars and lighters they are at war with
the government who has the government's
war on risk they say the government has
no right to keep us from smoking and so
they are literally giving out cigarettes
now I asked the question there are a lot
of cigarettes a lot of cigars a lot of
lighters and I said who's funding this
and there was a silence kind I said
there are the cigarette our Marlboros
because are they funding no no no no
follow the money Oh President Bush has
back in the spotlight with his book and
giving a lot of interviews you
interviewed Bush more than anyone else
and you wrote four books about him has
anything that's come out in the last
couple of weeks surprised you
ah no and and it's it's very consistent
and he's uh he's got a style that's very
chummy and you see that but he leaves
all kinds of things out and the third
book i did on bush showed that he hadn't
told the truth about how bad it was in
iraq he totally he compresses that whole
book down to a line of you know i wasn't
acting as aggressive as I should have on
Iraq but what he misses and I think it's
a shame he doesn't tell this story I
told it in the fourth book bush book
about the toll the presidency had taken
on him even after the third book I
thought the chances of getting an
interview were 0 for the fourth book but
he agreed for out to do hours of
interviews and at one point in the focus
was the surge in Iraq edition of 30,000
troops I said how did you come up with
30,000 and Steve Hadley who was the
National Security Advisor is there and
he said and he interrupts which is
totally I thought you know this is
really unusual very self-effacing person
and he said oh that was worked out
between me hadley national security
adviser and general paste the chairman
of the joint chiefs and I'm kind of
having you know what WTF means no no
what the I'm having a WTF moment and
Bush energetic said okay I don't know
that WTF moment to ah you know this is
his big decision this is in his book he
takes great credit for and then he says
incredibly he said I'm not at those
meetings you'll be happy to hear I was
just delighted I think why why why why
should the commander-in-chief be there
at the meeting to decide how many troops
to send to save the Iraq war which he
started which is defines his presidency
and then if that was WTF moment three
and then he delivered WTF moment for by
saying I've got other things to do it's
in the war within there it is but here's
the point the point is he was irritable
he was gray he was fatigued had a paunch
he was gray and the presidency had
fatigued him when he was working on his
memoirs I asked somebody was working
with him so well what's he doing down
there in Texas oh he's working on his
memoirs and recovering from the
presidency and something to think about
even with mr. young mr. Obama it
particularly in the age of terror any
phone call the phone rings you know what
what could it mean the next terror
attack the next calamity and so forth
and can somebody get out of that office
without the fatigue and you look at the
schedule Obama keeps you look at the
thing he does i'm doing four things here
at yale today and I'm you know I'm going
to be exhausted at the end he does eight
or ten things does this make sense let's
rethink it how long should the term be
what are the nature how do you organize
the presidency I think it's something
that that's out there but not really not
about six year term would be there might
be it might be maybe 12 year term I
don't know if it's it's it is really
hard and what so many presidents have
not done is found a way if you look at
Obama now economies number one issue
would everyone agree who's in charge of
the economy for Obama made Larry Summers
is leaving you know when the was the
head of the Economic Council to court
all of this there's Obama has not found
a way George Bush didn't really find a
way in many areas to kind of call is
Steve Brill in and say look you are in
you're going to be my mission manager
for the economy you're in charge of
everything i'm going to make the final
decisions keep me informed i want you 24
7 on this important issue who's that
person we don't have that person we have
in the wars in Afghanistan or Iraq Bob
gates but is that report in here obama
calls him in and says I want you to stay
for the whole term for years Gates has
agreed to stay for one year they agree
finally on two years but gates is
irritated he feels blindsided by the
whole thing and actually tells people he
felt like the president sounded like a
rug merchant trying to get him to stay
longer than he wanted to stay now you
know you've got the key person one foot
out the door how's the house the
organization going to function because
of you let me ask you one more question
then we'll take some from the crowd if
you were if you had the chance to
interview obama today and out of
character was on live television and you
could only put one question to him what
would it be oh boy because i don't want
you to describe you know your next three
our interviews yeah yeah about how what
would be the one question may i see i
don't think you ever and when i
interviewed him for this book i send him
a 20 page memo single-spaced linchpin
moments i called these were the key
decision points turning points and we
didn't get to the mall he wouldn't
answer it wouldn't give me enough time
because he wanted to compress it but i
think you don't I think there's not the
rosetta stone question I think what it
is is you lead somebody through whether
it's the president or the note-taker at
the NS
meetings or whoever you've got his
sources okay what happened here what
didn't mean what were you thinking and
that we think there's kind of a trick in
questioning I think the most important
question in any interrogation is why
when i interviewed bush for the second
book plan of attack how he decided to go
to war in iraq for three and a half
hours how many questions do you think i
got to ask him somebody from the
audience part two that would be if it
was Bill Clinton and that would be long
from that would be many I think you
could interview Clinton for three and a
half hours and not ask a single question
I asked both 500 questions yeah he gives
short direct answers and deposition in
and if you look at everything that's
been written since then those books hold
up and they have a lot more than he has
in his memoirs well there's a difference
also when you're doing interviews even
if it's with the present you're not a
television reporter or even daily
newspaper reporter looking for the great
quote you're looking for information
yeah exactly what happened why what were
you thinking what did you really feel
and bush we were thinking of publishing
all my bush memoirs before is of all my
Bush interviews directly with him is a
little book before decision points came
out as kind of you know this is what he
said before and is much much more
intimate it's much more I'm he says at
one point to me said if you're trying to
get into my mind that's okay I want you
in my you know his dad Bush Senior you
know would close the book on getting
into his mind but Bush invited it and in
many ways it's a much more nuanced real
emotional portrait
of his decision why don't we see you at
some table talk shows pardon why don't
we see you on the MSNBC chosen I am I go
on if it's something I've done a book on
or done some original reporting on but
yeah they'll call you I remember the
Chandra Levy case the woman who was
murdered who was having this affair with
the congressman though he didn't do it
allegedly and this was a big storm in
Washington and and the cable news would
call him say we want you on to talk
about this and I'd say well I don't know
anything and the invariably the answer
was that doesn't make any difference
that's what happens you have an opinion
there's three questions here about
WikiLeaks em so here's one of them what
do you think of the WikiLeaks authors
statement five people have done what the
whole media in the entire world couldn't
well I've looked at some of their
documents they don't change the
narrative they are mid-level not highly
classified documents frankly at this
point at the same time I think it's
madness to publish four hundred thousand
documents without reviewing that you
really could get somebody killed or an
operation now maybe that's their purpose
and if it is they ought to be clearer
about it but but the whole sale I mean
it's like I liken it to Nixon's taping
system it's madness you tape everything
you put everything out your it makes no
sense and five people did what no one
else could do but what is is WikiLeaks
going to be in the history books they
have people doing stories on Iraq or
Afghanistan and gone back and quoted
from those documents a couple of times
but not much if Sarah Palin were elected
to be president in 2012 what book about
her would you envision
my wife tells me sometimes it's best to
not answer a question can you talk about
but you know I mean look let's address
it what's she's a phenomenon she's I
personally think she's not running I
think she's having a field day and
enjoying it and making lots of money and
getting a lot of attention I suspect
she's let's hope she's smart enough to
realize that she is has not got the kind
of experience to me to make a chief
executive of the country but you know
sure could be wrong you talk about
different chiefs of staff and their
relationships with their presidents and
how those have affected other respective
White House decisions particularly in
the car turn clinton administration yeah
it wow i could spend too long answering
that the chief of staff's really
important Carter first had Hamilton
Jordan who was his political operative
and that's not the job that a chief of
staff should have that shouldn't be the
political operative David Axelrod is not
Obama's chief of staff the second one
was somebody named Jack Watson who was
kind of not that close but was a manager
I mean Clinton went through Chiefs of
Staff regularly well his first was Mack
McLarty who was his kindergarten boy
kindergarten boyhood friend from hope
Arkansas and that didn't work out the
the chumminess in kindergarten McLardy
was not effective I did the first
Clinton book the agenda and pointed out
in detail McClarty
was nothing right after the book came
out he was fired in leon panetta became
the chief of staff leon panetta called
me up and said thanks he'd been the
budget director so it's it's really i
don't think that presidents or academics
or just the government has thought
enough about how you organize the White
House organize the presidency and who
you delegate and how it's done I'm not I
don't think anyone has done a
particularly good job and I'm surprised
academics who often do things that don't
have meaning you could really get four
or five academics who really know this
do the interviewing do the work and come
out like this deficit Commission and say
this is the way you can improve
organization in the White House if you
could rewrite your book on Alan
Greenspan how different would it be ah
if this was the book that came out in
two thousand called maestro and if you
look at the record he was the maestro
during the growth period I didn't write
about him in the housing bubble which of
course happened many years later and one
of the things you've learned in writing
any form of journalism or book is that
you can't write about events that
haven't occurred and that that had not
occurred I do in the book explain
Greenspan's theory that you don't know
and in his in the case i write about was
the tech bubble you don't know there's
something's a bubble until it bursts and
of course that's what he did with the
housing bubble later and there was a
fallacy in that logic and i pointed it
out in in the book very vividly so if i
was writing a book about the whole
Greenspan time is fed chairman from 87
not just to 2000 but from 87 to I guess
2005 he left
I wouldn't call it maestra it's a couple
questions here about WMDs um do you
consider that a failure of the media not
to move to have found out that there
weren't WMDs in a row yes and I
particularly fault myself I was in a
position to know as much about this as
any reporter I had three sources who
told me this is before the war which
Bush launched in march of 2003 that the
fascinating I'm if you were still doing
brillz content you would three sources
say very well-placed sources that the
information about WMD in Iraq is
skimpier than they say ah and I thought
I was going to do a story about this I
went an editor said we'll do these three
sources think there is WMD in Iraq and I
went back to all three and they said yes
they think it's there but the evidence
is skimpy we don't have hard evidence I
wrote a story on the front page of the
Washington Post saying that there's no
smoking gun evidence that Iraq has WMD
now let's ask a lawyer Brill if you
don't have smoking gun evidence what do
you have you known evident you don't
have evidence you have nothing and it's
a case of I wrote something that I mount
lawyer realization to mention in case
there are real more is in room yeah okay
well that Yale Law School graduate
anyway well just what I meant yeah okay
well let's let that pass that if you
don't have smoking gun evidence you you
really don't have anything and I and
quite candidly I did not understand the
ramifications of what i wrote because I
should have I mean if or an editor
should have said hey Woodward you've
said there's no smoking gun evidence
well what is there
well no hard evidence will know her
what's the soft evidence and this would
lead you down a trail that would take
you to some stories with more doubt the
problem is and it goes back to this
process of trying to get to the bottom
of things the only way to get to the
bottom of that is to go to Iraq while
Saddam is still in power and knock on
doors now I don't think that they'd let
you do that in Iraq priest said well
Saddam was still in power it it's not so
how do you get information and how do
you get negative evidence but I counted
as one of my giant failures is a
journalist to not pursue them more
aggressively how did the Obama and
George W Bush administration's differ
operationally and in particular is
they're actually more transparency in
the Obama administration I don't know
about transparency I'm in the row all
hidden and you have to pry it out
operationally Obama's much more
thoughtful much more Bush told me said
I'm a gut player not a textbook player
true bush operated driven on instincts
if you look at the decision to go to war
in Iraq and he decided it on instinct
and all the meetings were about how to
do it they never had a meeting about
whether to do it which is shocking
really Obama is all textbook and a lot
of times these questions just don't get
answered how do you really show people
that you're interested in them as
themselves and I guess please teach us
you part but please teach us you do more
than a google search if you're
interviewing Steve Brill you get out his
terrific book on the Teamsters and you
read it you look at his other work
look at his you really do an analysis
and so you come to talk to him and
immediately through the questioning he's
going to understand hey this person is
taking me seriously they are serious
about their inquiry and you're going to
be much more willing to you again it's
it's it was down rumsfeld who used to
always talk about time against the
problem and i think it is time against
the problem that you've got to really be
immersed and people interview you a lot
right what's the what how do you
differentiate just giving them ten
minutes or for our way or if they start
either this I think I told my classes
last week I got a call about six weeks
ago from someone who a college was going
for his master's somewhere and he's
doing his master's thesis on the
Teamster so he gets found offensive can
you tell me what you know about the
Teamsters I said well would you like me
just to sit here and read a 588 page
book which by the way is 30 years old so
I don't know anything anymore anyway I
mean what yeah what kind of open-ended
you know that will also make you crazy
i'm sure if someone says to you know
what do you think about President Nixon
you you know there's that term Weston
but there's one situation where if you
really know something about someone that
they're very proud of but that is sort
of far in the past like i once called a
lawyer in south carolina for story i was
doing and he was representing JP stevens
against the textile workers remember
that was a huge deal when they were
busting unions but i wanted this guy to
talk to me a lot turns out for a period
of about eight weeks he'd been the
governor of south carolina because he'd
been a tenant governor and then the guy
left office in freight weeks he'd been
the governor of south carolina like 25
years before and I'm sort of a political
trivia guy so I knew it and I when he
got on the phone I addressed him as
governor it was just smooth sailing yeah
that's right yeah even if somebody
hasn't been a governor it's always good
no it's like yeah
open-ended governor stopped for speeding
you always address the cop as sergeant
or lieutenant yes that's right or
governor president brillar in the past
50 years we've seen the sensationalism
of journalism for the masses small
compressed stories and an emphasis on
your relevant stories this has happened
in TV also do you see an end to this
change I I think it's going to be there
in some form it may get discredited I
think the only way to push that out is
with the product that is so compelling
and so important and Tom Friedman wrote
a column the other day about this story
that was going around that the Obama's
trip to India and so forth cost 200
million dollars Iran today Cooper shut
it down yeah in the endorsing Cooper on
CNN said win 200 million that's uh
that's a lot of hotel rooms and a lot of
stuff and really drove it to ground
turned out maybe was five million a day
if that and but it was spread just like
wildfire and there's they're the people
who used it i don't think apologized or
corrected I know huffington post came
out with story after bush's memoir
saying he lifted a lot of information
from my books and elsewhere other books
and even you know I thought lifted and
somebody asked me about this and i had
read the book and i looked at it and I
put out kind of a statement to a couple
of people I said you know this is unfair
he's working from the record somewhat as
I did NSC notes and so forth he's talked
to people and a lot of these are his own
words and they're 200 pages of
transcript of my interviews with him
that I've used
and he's obviously used that others have
used that I mean how can you say lifted
it Keith Oberman it was going to do a
segment on this about Bush lifting and
somebody said he got the statement that
I'd put out and somebody else had said
some things and he actually came on the
air and said you know we're not doing
that segment because there's no story
there doesn't mean he just didn't walk
away from it he semi apologized that we
got caught in this vortex last questions
about Afghanistan why did President
Obama set the date of July 2011 and do
you think he now sees that as a mistake
he said it because in one of the
strategy session gates said I think we
can start drawing down or thinning out
our forces in 18 to 24 months and Obama
grabbed 18 grabbed 18 just like okay the
defense secretary said this and the same
way there's a secret memo the gates
wrote to Obama saying he could you know
30,000 might be okay and so Obama used
these two elements in his major decision
and it came from gates gates has told
people he doesn't remember saying the 18
to 24 months they could start thinning
out but it's in the it's in the NSC
record just one who if you'll bear with
I have one more story because there's
been kind of a sense of that we you know
we can get it right in journalism if you
do spend a long time and get documents
and interview people and I think that's
true but I also think it's true that you
can get it wrong and I tell this story
because it's I think it's an important
illustration of getting it wrong and it
was a month after Nixon resigned
Gerald Ford was present and some of you
may remember this Ford went on
television on it early on a Sunday
morning announcing is giving Nixon a
full pardon for Watergate ah now Ford
went on television early on a Sunday
morning hoping no one would notice but
it was widely noticed but not by me when
I was asleep in a hotel room in New York
City and my colleague at the time Carl
Bernstein called me and woke me up said
have you heard and I said I haven't
heard a thing I've been asleep and Carl
then and still has the ability to
explain what happened in the fewest
words with the most drama said the son
of a [ __ ] pardoned the son of a [ __ ]
happy to report even I was able to
figure out what head and for a long time
I thought the pardon something dirty
about it there was there was a deal the
question you know Ford would get the
presidency and agreement he would pardon
Nixon and there was this sense dear to
the hearts of I think most people in the
country of justice why does the guy at
the top get off 40 people went to jail a
lot of key Nixon aids and i thought this
for years and then i undertook the book
shadow about the legacy of Watergate in
the presidencies of ford through clinton
and called ford up and asked to
interview him suspecting he would
decline he said no fine and for hours i
interviewed him in New York Colorado
where he had a home California where he
had his main home and short to shorten
this he said look I pardoned Nixon not
for Nixon not for myself but for the
country we had to get over Watergate if
there was more investigations and
indictment a trial criminal trial of the
former president a
jailing perhaps of the president we
would have had years of more of
Watergate we needed to have get this
over I needed my own presidency and I
finally wrote this in the book and
Caroline Kennedy the daughter of JFK
called me and said I read this in your
book and you know I think that's right
and we're going to give Gerald Ford the
Profiles in Courage Award for pardoning
Richard Nixon and so there was Teddy
Kennedy and Caroline Kennedy giving it
for this award Ford beaming vindicated
in a sense 25 years later in history and
seared into my head is this idea you're
so sure it looks dirty corrupt or looks
right looks fine and then under neutral
examination through the eye of history
it turns exactly 180 degrees a very
important lesson particularly for people
in my business those who are on cable
news or blogging about you know this is
the way it is this is you know the Obama
presidency is over it can't be elected
or it's he'll turn it around we don't
know and we get off into making these
extreme judgments which I can understand
that affection people have for it's fun
to hear a prediction on the Chris
Matthews show who's going to win the
Democratic New Hampshire primary in 2016
by the nearest tenth of a percentage
point but it's irrelevant and takes us
away from the process of the past and
that's where i'm not sure we always get
it right thanks Bob
you